your new book feels like it was purpose
written for me massive fan of aphorisms
massive fan of pithy short life advice
for the people that haven't read it
I notice a trend throughout the entire
book which is one of optimism and hope
and at the moment I notice on the
internet a uh current
um rhythm of serious cynicism people
believing that the world can't improve
that the people who hope that it can are
the ones that are genuinely the problem
what's the case for optimism why should
people be optimistic at all
I think there's um
three reasons
why you should be optimistic as you
possibly can understanding that it's
somewhat a temperament but actually I
think it is a skill
and um the first reason is is that um if
you read any history at all you soon and
and look at the evidence and the actual
science you have to conclude that
progress is real and that the conditions
that generated that progress are still
working at work in the world and that
this will statistically probability
continue for a while
that's one reason the second reason is
that um
we know from the work of child
psychologists that people who are
optimistic Thrive better
that and that and they they they
understand they the psychologists
understand that one of the ways you
teach children is called learned
optimism
to be more optimistic is to have them
come to understand that setbacks are
only temporary
they're not they're inevitable but
they're only temporary
and then the third reason is is that um
uh
uh it's the optimists who actually are
creating all the cool things that we
need and that there is making our lives
better all the um Optimus is someone who
envisions a world or something they want
to have and can believe believes that
it's possible and that that belief in
that envisioning helped make it come
about because the really good things
that we want
are so complicated they're not going to
happen accidentally inadvertently
you actually have to imagine them and
have to believe that they're going to
happen and that requires optimism and
that's why basically it's the optimists
who are shaping our future
how much do you think that people can
nudge their disposition
one of the easiest ways is to change
your time Horizon
if you look out
Beyond just next year or the year after
10 years 20 years 30 years
it becomes much easier to be optimistic
because that
that slow growth that slow compounding
of progress
can overwhelm even fairly serious
setbacks and downturns
and disasters even
and so um which are hard to kind of
accept or even to to confront with the
short term but if you take a longer term
View
along Horizon
then you have the ability to kind of see
that they can be overcome and that goes
back then that the setbacks are just
temporary I suppose this stops you from
confusing noise for signal that you have
little UPS little downs but you're
trending in a direction over a broad
enough time Horizon the trend is obvious
right and this also has to do with just
the supreme power of compounding
interest compounding things so even if
you're only increasing or improving or
creating a few percent more than you
destroy if you compound that over time
it becomes a very very large consistent
force and then I guess the fourth thing
I would say is I am optimistic and I
think others should be too not because
of
um disregarding or dismissing our
problems we have to be real there are
problems and there will be leaving new
problems that are even more powerful
and optimistic not because the problems
I think are smaller
than we're aware of but because our
capacity to solve the problems is
increasing even faster
so
we're not being Pollyanna and dismissing
the the problems when you're optimistic
you're just saying no are we're trusting
the future of the future generations and
our own skill for solving problems
continues to increase
that's an amazing case for it I'm really
trying to rail against this
Trend this sort of uh fashion of
cynicism on the internet at the moment
and I really really want I've called it
toxic positivity uh because I needed to
come up with something and um I call it
radical optimism
and
um yeah radical optimism is my term for
it
actually my friend Louis has militant
optimism which I thought it was even
cooler that is cooler yeah right okay
first one don't be the best be the only
what's that mean foreign
this is sort of at the core of of the
book you may be my own philosophy
um it suggests that achieving the best
is kind of what we're taught to do is to
be the best in things
but the best by definition is a very
narrow like very narrow Niche there can
really only be one
and you're kind of limiting
um the numbers and your chances of
actually achieving that
and also because it's basically it's
someone else's definition of success it
also
um excludes most likely you and your own
particular set of abilities and
capabilities
and so um if you uh head towards
becoming the only
that's a much wide open area that is
potentially full of a billion different
onlys all of them pursuing something
different in in a certain sense what you
are getting to do is to invent a new
definition for success
all right does a there's a famous Naval
quote where he says become the best at
what you do keep defining redefining
what you do until this is the outcome
exactly
right so so you're you're kind of coming
up with your own definition of success
and aiming at that and and by the way
um it most likely should not include a
billion dollars
right because um you actually don't want
a billion dollars I mean literally this
is my other piece of advice not in a
book if whatever you do try your hardest
not to have a billion dollars because
it's gonna ruin your life and um a
couple million fine but not a billion
why
oh my gosh it's imprisoning it's a
burden
it's terrible for your kids it's
um it becomes it overtakes your life
uh it becomes never present you can't
actually spend it
um as fast as it will earn money back
and um
and then you're the only thing you can
do with it is give it away and that's
now another whole another job and for
all its own complications
and it takes over your life and so
you're now kind of a slave to to the
billion
I have a friend who owns a very big
sportswear company his net worth is
three times Drake's net worth so the one
of the most famous rounds network is
okay so it's like over two I think it's
he's worth two two in a bit bill right
okay
um I went to a place called Nando's in
the UK with him which is a famous
chicken chain that exists we sat down
for dinner on an evening time five
o'clock and he was sat playing on his
phone and his EA and his EA's PA was sat
a few tables across and they were
working to wear their laptops and I
remember thinking as I was sat with him
imagine the problems that Drake would
have encountered if he'd tried to come
for dinner at Nando's with me he
wouldn't have been able to get within
two miles of this location without being
absolutely mobbed and yet the guy that
sat upset me is sat there with no
security he sat there no one hassling
him no one really even paying attention
to him and what it got me thinking about
was the price that people pay for the
level of wealth that they have and that
there are differing prices that people
can pay maybe a billion full stop
regardless of your level of scrutiny is
something that you shouldn't try and aim
for but there's within that you think
about Drake it would be mobbed by by
Paparazzi and press and people will be
coming up to him and he wouldn't be able
to get any peace and he'd need a million
security guards and he'd have to speak
to the restaurant beforehand and to be
crowd control and this guy that sat
upset me gets to just play Sudoku on his
phone or do whatever he's doing
beforehand so the price you pay for the
wealth you have is something that I'd
never considered before well yeah I mean
there's a little bit of conflation
between wealth and fame so it's not
breaks wealth it's his Fame
and famous as you some of you definitely
do not want to to aim for at all
some people are famous inadvertently
like you know like Obama you can't
really help that but aiming for it is is
crazy because it is imprisoning and
completely debilitating for the very
reasons you say
so
um so that's something that you think
you might want but you really don't
um and and my advice on that is read a
book about any famous person really
famous person you'll see what the
consequences of that is
um it only begins in where you're
describing extends even further
um but wealth is is is equally and
equally but there's another kind of tax
that you pay
for it and that's maybe the best way to
put it is that there's definitely a tax
for that wealth and it will be paid out
in other things all is to say that when
you're defining your success
it should certainly include other things
than money because that's just simply
not the most important thing and
um it's uh you know your success and and
having been around the people who have a
billion dollars it's really funny
because the building they're asking the
same questions that all of us are asking
which is what do I do when I grow up
right no matter how old you are and the
billion dollars doesn't give them the
answer to that
okay it actually contributes to the
problem because like where do I go from
here and so um
um that
definition of success and and that's for
me the joy of seeing people who are
pursuing their own definition and it
might be that they um they've total
control their time which I think is one
of the highest forms of wealth rather
than much of money is that the most
abundant thing money is is abundant but
the scarcest thing is our own time
and having control of that is my
definition of true wealth
in your opinion then should people take
most of the opportunities that they can
to trade wealth for time
yes absolutely in fact that's what
really rich people try and do although
not very successfully but yes and and
and it's much easier you know I say you
know one of the bits of advice is that
you know
the rich have a lot of money
the wealthy have control their time and
it's much easier to be wealthy than rich
okay so I like to post when I'm with
among my my billionaire friends that I'm
the wealthiest there because I have
total control of my time I don't have to
worry about my Entourage the EAS the
personal assistants whatever it is it's
like no it's
I I have my time
what you do on your bad days matters
more than what you do on your good days
for sure and um
that is uh going back to the kind of
basic understanding we have now of
habits and that
um
what you
um want to do is have something that
will get you through the bad days
because everybody will have them and if
they stop you or ped you
um that's something you want to overcome
you want to be able to just kind of like
absorb them to to to understand that
okay today was a bad day I didn't get
much done or you know whatever I was
working on failed or it was rejected
whatever it is but tomorrow I get a try
again and do I'm gonna do again I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make some more
I'm gonna try another idea and
um
so your how you deal with the bad days
is really the um the secret to kind of
moving forward
Tim Ferriss once said uh he wanted to
design his life to be able to crush the
average Tuesday and I just thought it
was such a lovely way to put it and I I
spoke to a friend Rob Dyrdek recently
and he said he wants his average he's
optimizing for the normal Tuesday he
just wants the normal Tuesday to be as
enjoyable as possible that's okay I mean
think about that that's that's that's an
interesting way of um
right so the average Tuesday is your
best day I don't know if you're you say
optimized so he he wants it to be that
an average Tuesday has as much enjoyment
in it as possible Right does it need to
be spectacular right just needs to be
normal as good as it gets is your
average Tuesday
um yeah that would be
um
or or yeah I'm just you know you've got
me now trying to think about how I make
this into it the aphorus the aphorus is
coming out right yeah so but but the the
impulse I think is is correct and that
is
um you know your life basically is what
you make on your average Tuesday in a
certain sense that yes there's way more
average Tuesdays than there are Peak
experiences right so the um I love the
idea of a good bad day as well that you
get out of bed and oh there's been some
sort of nightmare at work or there's a
flood that the toilets backed up and
everything goes out the window and yet
when you look back at the end of the day
you still consider it a success or you
you are fulfilled or you right right
right right yeah so there's somebody
yeah making the your worst day still an
okay day or the you know something that
you can feel good about
yeah you're sort of that's interesting
is you're sort of trying to elevate not
your elevate your highest state but you
want to elevate your worst days so that
they're not so bad correct bringing that
safety net up right that's interesting
although yeah I mean
there are
disasters and things that can
be your new worst day you know
um having three kids and getting older
being around they're you know they're
just unexpected days are Way Beyond your
control yes they can become a bad day
well I suppose what you what you're
trying to optimize for is on average
higher lows rather than higher highs
exactly you want your average bad day to
be yeah okay okay
um the thing that made you weird as a
kid will make you successful as an adult
why I have seen so many people like this
oh I think you forgot the last part if
you don't lose it
so so the idea is is is is that a lot of
people are kind of weird as a kid and
they kind of put that behind them
but you want to keep that thing you want
you want to to nourish it in some way
and cherish it and it's not just the
child likeness it's the fact that
um
there's something in you that's
inherently different than others and
it's that difference that we're trying
to
accentuate and emphasize and grow and
cultivate because the difference is what
makes the
wealth and Innovation and all these
other
things possible and the reason why we're
not being duplicated by robots the more
the more special and unique and weird
you are the less likely you're going to
be replaced by AI
so um so that kind of weirdness in them
is is often a suggestion a reflection of
your inherent makeup and dispositions
and tendencies and abilities and we tend
to get them beat out of us
as we go through school
and looking for a job and trying to be
the best in something
um and so if you can retain some of that
or return to it I think you have a
higher chance of being the only rather
than being the best I love that I think
it's
a more pure view into your or a clearer
view of your passions before they become
molested or perverted by other
incentives by money by status by
Prestige by sex all those things I
remember reading this amazing story
about one of the world's most successful
color Pickers so this lady would choose
color wheels for the best fashion houses
in the world the best interior design
companies in the world there was an
interview that was done with her and she
was asked how is it that you're so good
you've been the best in your field at
this what's your training been like talk
me through your process and she said
well to be honest I I'm not formally
trained in this but when I was nine
years old my parents bought me the
biggest Crayola crayon set that was
available and I used every single one of
them down to the nub and I thought that
is somebody who was weird in childhood
and didn't lose it when they got to
adulthood exactly and there's tons and
tons of stories i i encountering people
like that all the time
um and and you know a lot of people I
mean basically you you ideally you'll
have a
a business card and your occupation
should be pretty unique to yourself and
that is happening um all the time right
now today that's the to me the the
beauty of technology and why I'm a big
booster of it is that it gives us more
and more options it permits more and
more people to find their genius and
share it in ways that you could not do
before the invention of you know the
symphony or or Cinema or
um laser uh all these enable
um new ways of expressing and somebody
somewhere is born with that right
combination if we can get them matched
up
a great way to understand yourself is to
seriously reflect on everything you find
irritating in others mm-hmm
yeah there's a little bit of a
if you find it irritating
it's a signal
that this is resonating with you in a
certain way and it doesn't mean that you
are like that it just means that you
have something in you that's
particularly attuned to this and that
you should investigate it to be sure
that you are not like it but even if you
are not like it it that is indicating
that something about yourself
that you haven't really kind of explored
yet and and I think my basic premise I
know this from the Quantified Self
movement which we started is that we're
opaque to ourselves
we're kind of like the last to know
about ourselves in many ways both
collectively as humans we don't know how
our brains work and why we do things but
even individually
we have
um
we're blocked in some ways from uh
accessing our true understanding of
ourselves or even our memories our
motivations and we need a lot of
discipline as well as outside help to
understand ourselves and this is another
tool in that toolkit of trying to come
to understanding about ourselves
there is a when you see somebody else
that is being irritating
it activates inside of you it triggers
something inside of you which resonates
with with a part of your own makeup
right I am I totally totally agree I
think that
it's so interesting to consider how
self-deceptive we are you know
evolutionarily it makes total sense if
you need to kid everybody else that
you're not a complete freak that talks
to themselves in the shower right does
all of the Myriad weird idiosyncrasies
stuff
the best way to convince them that
you're not mental is to not believe that
you're mental yourself which means that
you are the easiest person to Fool by
yourself and the last person to know and
and also there is also another
evolutionary Advantage which is you
really don't
what
the ego to be able to mess around too
much in in your fundamental operating
system absolutely oh the base the base
code should not be right and so you
don't really want to have easy access to
that because you'll be messing around
with it otherwise and so there's a kind
of a deliberate distancing that we do
just to to job keep operating protect
the vital systems exactly yeah well I
mean imagine to take it to an extreme
imagine if you had to consciously think
every time you wanted to breathe or
every time you wanted to digest food you
know it's just a difference of degree to
roll that up towards your view of your
own status or what you find attractive
or Etc
yeah you can ignore any website with the
word truth in its URL
yeah
uh and then the email with with
something similar with with a with a
really good bargain
um
yeah it's it's
most of my knowledge has been
um I'm channeling the Ancients and the
stoics in the Bible this is not one of
them this is a much more contemporary
one based on my own experience and what
I've seen in the world so um
I could be wrong about that but
generally that's a good heuristic and
rule of thumb
what do you think about the you can
ignore any science that's got the word
science in the title heuristic I haven't
heard that one
social science like Christian Science
um yes yes social science uh yeah
um
I don't I wouldn't say we could ignore
it but um
yeah that there is a parallel I had not
thought about that
um
what it what it means is that um you
need a lot more evidence so like any
kind of even whether the social science
but even in medicine
you we can't really make policy based on
just one or two studies we need you need
hundreds of studies and that's because
the body and sociology is so complex
that even unlike physics where one or
two experiments can tell you a lot in
these arenas
you need hundreds of experiments Maria
more multivariate right just over time
all kinds of uh variables included and
so by the way this is why I'm very very
reluctant to
make policy now based on social media
because we haven't done the hundreds of
experiments there's one or two
experiments about the consequences of
social media and it's just like it's
like having one or two medical studies
you you just should not be making policy
based on just the handful that have been
done mostly in the US and not even
around the world so
um so I'm a big advocate of more and
more constant testing and knowledge and
investigation
and and and and and persistent doing it
again unlike the FDA where they do it
once and then they approve it and then
they were tested again that's also not
really
um modern and so uh
so right now we just and AI will be it's
a whole other thing because we've done
almost zero and it's like a year old who
knows anything so trying to
make policy based on whatever might have
come up is just completely ridiculous we
just don't know enough yet
don't be afraid to ask a question that
may sound stupid because 90 of the time
everyone else is thinking of the same
question and is too embarrassed to ask
it right so so I was a kid
who sat in class up in the front row
and I asked all the stupid questions and
um people would come up to me all the
time
saying thank you for asking that
question I was too embarrassed to ask it
so
um
and for some reason I wasn't embarrassed
to ask this stupid question why do you
think that's the case how can people
become less embarrassed to be stupid
I don't really know the answer to that
one
um
I've never lacked self-confidence and
that's another question people have is
words to come from or where do you get
it and I don't know
um
I I think it may have something to do
with a lack of empathy meaning that I
kind of didn't care what other people
thought
he's thinking about other people and I
was not thinking about other people it
was like I wasn't asking the question
for their sake
I genuinely had the stupid question that
was my question and so it wasn't as if
I'm thinking oh I'm going to ask a
question because for the benefit of
others no no no it was like it's an
altruistic this is completely selfish at
all I was just a stupid guy who was
naive enough to to say I don't know what
you're talking about nailed it so a a
good parallel to what I've done on the
show
I ask you know thousands of questions
yeah to people on this podcast the
questions that get the most uh praise or
thanks in the comments are when I'll say
what's that word mean
that someone someone used the word uh
bivalve the other day and what's that
you go it's like an oyster oh thank you
um those are the the most stupid I I I
thought that I didn't know what a Bible
I was the only one that wasn't bivalve
pilled on this podcast and it turns out
it turns out that other people are as
well so yeah I you know it this goes all
the way up it's outside of school it's
outside of everything right right and by
the way uh you know I I'm a born editor
rather than a writer and I edited
magazines and wire and this is something
that I was doing that I would do when
editing is I am representing the reader
at that point but mostly again it's for
me and that it was if I did not truly
understand something it was like
you gotta explain it to me because what
do you mean by that what do you mean by
that because I don't understand it and
you and so but there was also a balance
by the way because there's also a
tendency in journalism particularly
newspaper journalism to have to explain
everything over and over again aiming to
the kind of 11 year old where for a
while in the 90s
if you use the word DNA you had
explained you had to say DNA that thing
that you know whatever it was like I
know what DNA is I don't need to hear
that I suppose here's an interesting
insight there as new Fields open up the
conceptual inertia hasn't propagated
sufficiently quickly which means that
you end up with much more clunky
articles for a short period of time
until the whatever cultural Overton
window has caught up and now everyone's
back in right so it would be like here's
here's the kind of test you're going to
write an article about something like so
you mentioned the word chat gbt do you
need to explain it or not
it depends who you're writing for right
writing for your mum right so so my
advice to the people at wired writers
this is my standard device to the
writers
you're not writing to your mom you're
not writing to the 11th grader
you're writing to me I am your audience
I am bored
you have to amaze me
and so if it's something so you're
trying to guess what is it that I know
of course right um so I know about chat
gbt so the info wired it would
definitely would not be explaining it by
now
um Transformer model large language
models
probably not I don't know
but but this is a balancing act between
you know bivalve would I um I have to
explain that in an article for Wired
I want to know what the article in white
is it's talking about oysters yeah um
yeah that's fascinating you know I think
about it a lot on the show as well
how much how
um how much brevity can I get away with
yeah how much is too much how much color
brings people along for the ride how
much patronizes them
um it's a real a real Balancing Act and
some days you know you come in and you
think this is the first time that we
have ever spoken about the evolutionary
basis for bullying I had this guy called
Tony Volk on the show recently okay I
need to hear your definition I need to
hear why it's adaptive I need to hear
who does it whether it's heritable all
the way down
and then you as your learning goes along
but that's the perfect way that you said
it if you presume that you are somewhere
close to the aggregate Avatar of the
audience that you're speaking to would
you need it ex when you learned it did
you need to explain it to you right did
you need to go and do tons of research
if so you may need to pass that on if
not if you thought yeah of course I know
what that is maybe you know if you've
become intimately familiar with bivalves
you're probably fine so so when we were
drawing wired we had the advantage that
we were starting wired and basically
there wasn't the audience and so we said
we are making a magazine that we want to
read and basically we're going to find
other people
who
you know are like us
right that that's what we're doing we're
writing an article so we're going to
attract the people who are like us
okay so so if you talk at my level we're
going to attract people that are
interested and it turned out to be a lot
of people wanted to have that kind of a
conversation at our level
so we found them or they found us
because they they would open up the
thing and they would hear this
conversation at our level and they would
go I that's me this is for me this is my
tribe you're talking at the right level
that I'm at
yep prototype your life try stuff
instead of making Grand plans so this is
really the subtitle of my book wisdom I
wish I'd known earlier it just took me
way way too long to kind of get there
there's a very in um what's the word I
want literal meaning of prototyping
where you know I do I make a lot of
stuff like I can't show you but I make
I've been a maker all my life I'm making
things still and it took me a long time
to get to understand that you can only
make a really great thing by prototyping
it along the way this even this I've now
taken it to heart and even this book I
prototyped and made little versions of
it bound books these happen to have
Doodles that the
publisher rejected but
um excuse me
um so I I think
um
that's the literal sense of actually you
know when I'm making a writing a book
I'm going to literally write a first
draft all the way through to the end
that will kind of be thrown away
the Builder people call build one to
throw away you and that idea of like
making a chair
all the way and then just to kind of
discard it to make the better one that
was just so that was just so hard for me
to kind of accept as a as a efficient
way to do it or is as because making one
thing anyway to the end was such a such
a challenge and so hard that you know
just doing it to throw it away seemed
crazy but that is really what I
discovered the only way you can make
something really great and so
um uh this idea though expands to Beyond
just a project is to if you're trying to
start a business or something rather
than quitting your job and
getting a lot of money and making A
Five-Year Plan you prototype it by
trying something for three weeks or just
see how far you can do with the with 10
products or ten items that you're trying
to sell or make or you do with the
Airbnb guides when they were prototyping
airbnbs you know they had some air
mattresses and they were going door to
door taking pictures of people who were
having the air mattress in their house
and it was
a prototyping stage so there's it's low
commitment High leverage learning
experiment where you're iterating your
way to a greater success and that's I
think the approach that works in life as
well
um I can't tell you the number of people
that I've met who went through school
did a graduate grade and wanted to
become a lawyer so they're in law school
and then they graduate within five weeks
of working a law firm that they realize
they hate it
they never once like did an internship
or volunteered at a lawyer just to hang
around to see
what it was you want to prototype you
just don't want to go that way that's
stress test your assumptions yes the
whole way
your assumptions
try out something do a version of it
that's a mock-up
when we did our kitchen remodel I did a
full scale model of the remodel in
cardboard from refrigerator cardboard
with duct tape and then you can learn
incredible amount of seeing the real
size things like oh this shouldn't be
here this should be over here this
should be a little bit higher and
um that's
the best approach I think to both
projects and life
I've got one of my favorite ones I came
up with a number of years ago which was
a note to myself which is perfectionism
is procrastination masquerading as
quality control
that's probably true for some people
I think a lot of people uh optimize for
perfecting rather than shipping at a
pace required to work out what works
right because they never have to face
real world rejection or failure by
keeping everything behind the scenes
right and that's also something that
I've learned again from blogging and
being at wired was um this idea of
sharing your work really early before
it's done in order to get feedback
because once it's done it's really hard
to change and so there's this idea of
that I do now of writing out loud I call
it writing out loud writing publicly in
versus I mean I'm again I'm always
impressed by the Fantastic musical
Hamilton the way that they Workshop that
for a decade just trying and trying in
life and getting the feedback and
changing it and so that is that's when
that's the best time to get feedback is
before you're done here's the other
thing as well involving somebody in the
process of a creative work gets them to
be more bought in than you can imagine
so I'm doing some live shows solo live
shows towards the end of this year I'm
going to do some work in progress shows
between now and then I need to get in
front of a room of 20 to 50 people
before I stand at Leicester Square
theater on a Sunday night sold out in
London
um and I'm gonna have probably a laptop
or an iPad attached to my hand you know
it's going to be messy there won't be
music it'll be blah blah the money will
go to charity for the people that come
along
but I would wager that the people who
get to say to their friends
I went to go and see that in progress
show you know and it was actually really
interesting so I got to observe it out
loud
uh you know we used to do this with um
with club nights too so I run nightclubs
for a very long time before we released
the brand what we would do is we would
involve the most influential guys and
girls that go out and party in town in
the process well you know if the room
two music upstairs do we want to go sort
of more Tech house or do we want to go
more tropical house we don't care about
their feedback we wouldn't take their
feedback on board we knew what we wanted
to do with regards to this event but
they would feel when the night was
finally announced that they had almost a
sense of ownership they were emotionally
invested so yeah I think asking people
for feedback and you'll have seen
Jonathan height is basically writing his
book on sub stack and you know this is
the the most direct example that I could
think of to what you're saying
I wrote my book on my blog
um uh and and so uh it's the the smart
authors realize the value of this and
and here's the thing you get you get all
the all the mistakes and Corrections
corrected very early because the
internet is really good at correction
right and so um and then you get extra
ideas of what did you think about that
did you know about that no I didn't
thank you so much
um and it's much more embarrassing to
get that later on when it's published so
yes that that aspect of of writing out
loud of um creating you say collectively
creating with your audience co-creating
things it's just super super under
underappreciated and the often the
hesitancy
for people is they're afraid someone's
gonna steal their idea
and this goes back to
um don't be the best be the only when
you're the only that's not a problem
okay so I came to this kind of
realization myself through my efforts at
wired where I was trying to assign a
story we had story ideas and we have
here's a great story we find find
writers to write these ideas and I'd
have an idea that I thought was really
great and I just simply could not give
it to anybody I could not sell it to
them for years I try again and again try
to kill off the idea there's no good but
then we come back and I think it is good
but I just can't get anybody to write it
and then eventually I'd realize after a
year said oh I have to write it
and while I was writing it and it wasn't
there wasn't any competition there
wasn't I was I could take my time
because I had been trying to give it
away for so long so this idea of like
nine now when I'm working on something I
talk about it to everybody
hoping that someone will take it because
if they take it that means I don't have
to do it that wasn't for me
all right and so you can be generous if
you're really trying to do something you
can be generous in sharing your work
early
because no one else is going to take it
and if they do good for them
so you should over overcome the
hesitancy about sharing things if you're
really working on something that's only
you
pain is inevitable suffering is optional
yeah
we unders you know humans I think
animals feel pain we don't think that
they suffer very much
um
in that way that we do
so it's sort of uh
yeah we feel pain that's
inevitable but we can turn it into
suffering by
what's the word by being victimized by
it and so
if we decide that
um this is pain and we will try and deal
with the pain we don't have to suffer
and I think the difference is
um
here's what it is I think
pain is outside
suffering is internal
pain is a is an external thing and
suffering is more of an identity
and you don't want that pain to become
your identity
you want it to be something that is a
trait something that you are
something that surrounds you rather than
something that's integral to you
one of the ways you learn optimism
and teach optimism to kids and optimism
is a skill you can learn is to
understand that um
as a kid to setbacks are only temporary
they're not your identity you're not
saying oh I am an unlucky person
and suffering has a little bit of that
sense of an acceptance of a fate
of an identity rather than the pain
which is external and can be overcome
you can't reason someone out of a notion
that they didn't reason themselves into
so I have another aphorism that I'm
working on that haven't actually
published it and so I don't have the
words down but
um most arguments are not about the
argument
they're usually they're usually I just
usually about something else at an
emotional level something else that
identity level something else that is
subconscious level and so
that's where a lot of our views come
from most of the our views are inherited
they're given to us
we kind of accumulate them without even
being aware of it
um and so trying to get out of that
through a logical process is just simply
usually not going to work
and that's why I say one of the best
ways to change someone's mind is to
listen to them very carefully and try to
understand
why they believe what they're believing
and you actually get more
you get further along in helping them
change their mind that way than actually
by arguing with them
yeah it's uh it also probably saves you
an awful lot of time right from trying
to uh drowning yourself whilst trying to
save somebody else who refuses to swim
in in whatever argument they're doing
right I have a friend who's got a
gwynda's theory of bespoke many
don't have an opinion until they're
asked for it at which point they Cobble
together a Viewpoint from a whim and
half remembered hearsay before deciding
that this two minute old makeshift
opinion will be their new Hill to die on
right well somewhere else I give advice
that um
you have you can get more respect for
your opinions if you're able to
be able to State the other side as well
as the other side could
and that you really shouldn't
um be offering your opinions unless you
are prepared to kind of be able to
explain it to that to that level of
understanding the other side
and so that's a again that's a very high
bar and this should be a high bar
for for pontificating on say
controversial things is that you should
be able to State the other side to the
satisfaction of the other along now we
ran a debate series
and that was one of the conditions of
the debate was once I would State their
premise or their idea and the other side
had to restate it to the satisfaction
of that first one before you can move on
and that's by the way that's a that's a
pretty big hurdle for a lot of people
well this is the thing about being
convinced by anything you don't really
get to choose what you're convinced by
there are degrees of self-deception that
people can go through and sort of
willful self-deception as well I I
suppose
but if you were convinced by the thing
that the other side is convinced by you
would also be convinced by it right so
it is very important and it's such a
good tool steel Manning is such a good
tool to turn down the volume of
antagonism and adversarialness uh that
occurs I'm currently writing a book at
the moment and everything that we're
doing in it is to give theory of Mind
from one group to another group right
like have you ever considered what it's
like to be this person have you ever
considered what it's like to be the
other person right here as soon as you
do it you just realize oh God yeah maybe
maybe it's not overblown maybe maybe
they genuinely do have a case here maybe
they do genuinely suffer in ways that I
couldn't foresee yeah absolutely
um and usually it's not a lack of
information
or information itself that that is
changing people's minds and so
[Music]
um
yeah so you don't have to attend every
argument that you're invited to
trust me there is no them yeah
it's a little hard to explain
but that's born out of my own experience
and working with my kids too
um
there's no them
because
most people are not because of
incompetency rather than anything else
right I mean they're just the the them
that you would imagine
requires a degree of Competency and
collaboration and whatnot
um to work and that's why power you know
being paranoia
is not really
useful because
the universe isn't really conspiring
they're just not capable of it
um and so uh
that then
doesn't I want to be sure to indicate
that there is there are systems that
have a Prejudice there is systematic
racism in the world so there is a there
is a A system that will
be biased but there's still none of them
there because even because the people
who are involved in that system are not
even willing and not necessarily
collaborating they're not being
deliberate so there are in the so the
individuals are not the them there can
be certainly A system that is biased but
when you meet someone it's not to them
and there's no real
there's no real ability
to conspire against you in the way you
might imagine
I've come upon the exact same thing I've
just given it a different name so Andrew
Schultz comedian from New York very
funny guy he taught me this lesson and I
renamed it Schultz's razor so it's not
coordination it's cowardice Schultz
taught me a great lesson during our
episode this is him quote a lot of the
time we believe that there is a grand
plan at work to try and push a narrative
or hurt people from a particular group
from the outside it looked like a
coordinated assault collusion
orchestrated by some malign Overlord
conspiracy but on the ground it doesn't
look anything like that it's just
individuals trying to save their own
skin and not get fired they've got an
expensive house they can barely pay the
mortgage on and a wife who wants a new
car and private school for their kids it
is much easier to just adhere to
whatever ideology will keep them in
their job rather than go against it sure
it might mean that they push an unhinged
story about children or ban somebody for
saying something innocuous from a
platform but this doesn't mean that
they've been indoctrinated into some
grand plan the incentives encourage
execs influential actors and the people
in power to behave in particular blind
ways but that coordination is not
consciously conducted it's just the path
of least resistance for each person yeah
I agree that that's a very good
description of it
um so while that's true and then
I would reduce it to there's no them
there's no that I should have just said
that's not them that would have been
quicker 10 to the small things more
people are defeated by blisters than
mountains
and by the way there's again two literal
things of this I I do these walk-in
talks where we invite people and we walk
and um there are people who are very fit
who are very healthy
um and they could climb a mountain but
they're just brought Low by a little
tiny blister because they bought new
shoes don't ever buy new shoes for a
long hike and so um
so yeah the Small Things metaphorically
um can bring down so you you do want to
make sure that you pay your taxes right
and you do want to make sure that your
bank accounts are balanced and all that
kind of stuff in order to to do the
really great things that you are called
to do
I often think about the
um very normal everyday things that the
most excellent people have to do yeah
and um I I this really sort of points
the finger at it quite nicely there's
another one here and this I think might
be the one that resonated with me the
most despite the fact that it's the
least applicable to me
you lead by letting others know what you
expect of them which may exceed what
they expect of themselves provide them a
reputation that they can step up to I
thought that was very very interesting
yeah I I I think I got a little bit from
um Steve Jobs in his attitude of of
leadership of really and I had a I had a
track coach that was the same thing is
like
he led by
leading me to believe in my capabilities
beyond what I believed myself and he
kind of
pointed to this things and believed that
I would get there and I did get there
um even though that I didn't see that so
he kind of led me into stepping up
myself and and I see that in great
leaders and people who work with them
getting their best and there was this
belief and the person seemed
unreasonable at the time who demanded a
certain level of
excellence and performance that
the employees at the time didn't really
think was possible but
this person knew
could see in them that they were capable
and led them by expecting it from him
how can people become better either as
recipients or as broadcasters of finding
that balance between tyranny and
Desperation
it is you're right it is a balance
Because by the way
Steve Jobs was a really mean guy who
certainly went overboard with this in
his demands
um
I think you
I think you have to look at the people
that you are guiding whether they remain
healthy if they're if they're truly if
their marriages are suffering if they're
children are complaining about them if
other things in their life are not
working then then you're probably
pressing too hard
the if you're really that this works and
enlarges the wholeness of a person at
its best if it's not doing that then
it's probably too much
so I think this was the Amish the story
of the Amish who when are still deciding
about new technology in which to accept
it and they will let the early adopter
Amish
there are earlier Dr Amish adopt new
things but they were saying we're
watching you and your family and how you
treat people and what you're doing with
your day as an evaluation of whether we
you should continue to use this stuff
and so that idea of
um you know Steve Jobs is
weakness was probably not in paying
attention to that whole person just
looking at their performance at work and
forgetting the fact that this would be
having an impact on the rest of them if
they were paying attention to that he
could see whether or not this was a
positive for them or a negative
right now no matter your age these are
your golden years yeah the good stuff
will yield Golden Memories and the bad
stuff will yield golden lessons yeah
these are your golden years it's not
when you're 70 it's like right now you
are living in your golden years
this is it and um
that is going back to your kind of like
your best
bad day
these are your best bad years in a
certain sense it's like yeah no you want
you want to celebrate this year because
this is like as good as it's going to
get which will be true for next year too
but
um this idea of kind of celebrating the
present as as the best and um I have a
friend who well his name is Hugh Howie
he's now uh this week last week his new
story was put on to Amazon Prime The
Silo stories one of my friends has told
me that I need to watch that it was
written by Hugh and he started off
writing he was a bookstore Clerk and he
started writing little chapters that
were all put on Amazon and he he made it
succeeded Beyond The Stream but the
thing was
was optioned and um
taking through many many steps and it
was like each time it was go through and
then it would be fail and then that
someone else would pick it up and then
there'd be you know casting it would
collapse there and there was this thing
and he was saying what he learned to do
was that each time it moved a step ahead
he would celebrate as if that's as far
as it was going to go
um like it was option okay we're gonna
have a celebration because it's probably
not going to go any beyond that and so
at every moment he's celebrating the
thing as if that was the victory yeah so
you do the sense of these intermediate
victories become
you accept them as that well it may not
go any further than that so we're going
to celebrate this and I think you can do
the same thing with your years it's like
you may not have additional years so why
not celebrate this as the best year of
your life
I think a lot of people presume that if
they give themselves an out in some
regard if they celebrate too much that
it's going to kill their drive but if
you look at the relative balance between
how much people over celebrate and how
much people over uh whip themselves
flagellate themselves because they're
not they're Puritan work ethic uh it's
way more on the other side there's a
related concept that I learned about
called deferred happiness syndrome the
common feeling that your life has not
begun that your present reality is a
mere Prelude to some idyllic future this
idle is a mirage that'll fade as you
approach revealing that the Prelude you
rushed through was in fact the one to
your death yeah I think you're right
there's no Prelude right this is it and
um that that's another piece of advice
that I wrote recently that's not in the
book which is um
don't save the best China and the best
wine for some
date that's never going to happen you
use them as much as possible now because
this is this is the time to celebrate
scratch the Rolex yeah I agree
um whenever you have a choice between
being right or being kind be kind no
exceptions don't confuse kindness with
weakness yeah
yeah so
you can't be too kind that's that's true
and that's
um
it's related to another piece of advice
I have about attending as many funerals
as you can and listen to what people say
um
my observation was having done this
recently is
almost nobody talks about the
achievements of The Departed
they talk about
what they were like how they made them
feel whether they were kind or funny or
helpful and so those are the qualities
that we remember and that means in
certain sense
they may become the most important
qualities that we have and um
kindness is always at the Forefront and
it's a kind of empathy and a kind of um
uh
it's an acceptance of the general
I think it's it's it's it's being
realistic about the actual state of
humans which is that we tend to be at
our heart
kind-hearted helpful and selfless given
all things being equal and what we're
taught in school that we're selfish as a
premise is wrong
and if you accept the fact that kindness
is
always according to people will be kind
to you in return which is really weird
but there is this weird Paradox which is
that the more you give the more you get
and that's true for everybody and
mathematically that does not add up
but that is the foundation of the
universe and when you're kind it's the
probably the most selfish thing you can
do correct people are going to treat you
their best and so weirdly paradoxically
the selfiest thing you can do is to be
kind
what would be a scenario where you need
to make a choice between being right or
being kind
oh all the time
um
oh
particularly like
I don't know if if there's a
um
you told someone you tried to help
someone
they didn't do what you suggested and
um
it didn't work out
being right would be reminding them
about that that you were right
being kind would be not to mention that
um that's this one kind of trivial
example but um there is a
uh all the time I I see this in
marriages all the time where you can be
like yeah I can be right this is this is
the thing to do but the kindness would
suggest
um you do it so so my wife and I this
thing where we can all rotate and them
always being right
and so this idea is like you're always
right I'm gonna it's right and that's
kindness and not rightness because we're
not saying whether they're really right
you're saying we're treating you as if
you're right so that's
that works that it works very very
powerfully because because basically it
is in alignment with the general drift
of the universe of humanness which is
that we are basically kind
the other thing it does is it accounts
for our irrationality you know we're not
utility optimizers right if we were then
you would always want the most right
answer at all times right but you're not
you're emotional and and you're going to
take things not based on the facts but
based on the way that you feel it's
another a really great quote that I love
that says karma is just you repeating
your patterns virtues and flaws until
you finally get what you deserve
well C.S Lewis
talked about his definition of Heaven
and Hell
it's in heaven and hell are basically
taking take you as you are right now
and what you're becoming and just make
it infinite
right so wherever you are so if you're
kind of a person who's been cheating
people and is just
kind of out for themselves and it's like
okay you just keep extending that
infinitely
that's hell if you're a person doing
your better and going a little bit
better
that's heaven so it's it's your current
trajectory just multiply by Infinity
Kevin Kelly ladies and gentlemen Kevin I
really appreciate you I think this works
fantastic uh as like I say the fledgling
aphorist in me is uh really really
impressed by this excellent advice for
living everybody should go and check
that out uh is there anything else
anywhere else you want to direct people
um not really I I appreciate the
attention
um people can find me at my website
which is my initials kk.org I'm on the
socials as well where I published my art
every day
um I do have a recommend a newsletter
which we've done for six years it's free
every Sunday and it's the recommended
stuff is one page
um and you'll
so people can sign up for that but
mostly
um take a look at the book and by the
way the one thing I've learned about
doing this recently is that um
if you have kids
generally the kids won't pay any
attention to the advice you give but you
can point them to a book the other
expert and they'll pay attention to that
so
um it really works great in that respect
Kevin thank you very much for today
thank you I really appreciate it was fun
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace